[APPLAUSE]
LEE BILLINGS: All
right, all right.
Well, it's really
good to be here.
Thanks.
And yeah, so actually
this is the quote
that I open the book
with, and I think
it's appropriate that I open
the presentation with it too.
This is from Werner Von
Braun, the architect
of Apollo's-- I'm sorry,
NASA's Apollo Program.
"Here on Earth we
live on a planet
that is in orbit around the sun.
The sun itself is a
star, which is on fire
and will someday burn up,
leaving our solar system
uninhabitable.
Therefore, we must build
a bridge to the stars
because, as far as we know,
we are the only sentient
creatures in the
entire universe.
When do we start building
that bridge to the stars?
We begin as soon as we are
able, and this is that time.
We must not fail
in this obligation
we have to keep alive the only
meaningful life we know of."
And I chose that
to open up the book
and open up this conversation,
this presentation,
just because I think it
encapsulates what the book is
really about, and what I think
space exploration should really
be about, at least maybe it was
about what Von Braun thought
it was about back when he was
building the Apollo rockets.
Some people seem to think
that my book is really
about the question of life
elsewhere in the universe,
but that's not exactly true.
It's really much more about--
well, it is about exoplanets,
and it's about the
search for other earths,
other Earth-like exoplanets.
But it's much more about
our own Earth and our lives
right here, which
we too often forget
our own planet is an exoplanet
to every star in the sky
except for one.
So you can look
around, and you think
about what an alien
biosphere is like, what
it's like to be an
alien on an exoplanet.
Look around you,
look in a mirror,
look at things in
nature outside.
And it's a perspective
that's valuable,
if it's a little prosaic.
So it's really not
so much about life
out there, the book, as it is
about life right here right
now, and what life really
does once it's get started
on an Earth-like planet.
What are we going to do
with our moment in the sun?
Where are we going to take it?
So that's kind of
where I start out,
and that's really what
the book tries to explore.
And this is the
cover, obviously.
I know it's already been
plastered up everywhere.
The title, I have to say, with
apologies to Gabriel Garcia
Marquez, it's not
inspired by "One Hundred
Years of Solitude."
A lot of people
seem to think it is.
It's not.
It's actually inspired by
the lifespan of the biosphere
as far as we know.
The Earth is about four and
a half billion years old.
We know that from dating
meteorites and really old
rocks.
And we can look and see
within those rocks, at least
the earliest ones we really
have that are well-preserved,
that life got
started here pretty
quick after the Earth cooled
from the great impacts that
formed it.
So our planet's been
alive almost as long
as it's been around, so
you get 4.5 billion years.
The lifespan of the
biosphere, obviously,
start with that
4.5 billion years,
and then you project
into the future.
Well, back in the
day, astronomers
used to say the end
of the world, the end
of the biosphere, would come
about five billion years
from now, when the sun
becomes a red giant.
The sun, obviously,
you know is a star that
changes as it evolves.
Becomes this big
red giant, goes out
to about two astronomical units,
engulfs the inner planets,
and that's the end of
life on Earth, right?
Well, a little later
on, planetary scientists
said, OK, well, sure, you
know, that's going to happen,
and the Earth's crust will
be melted down to slag.
But before that, about two
billion years before that,
or about two billion
years from now,
we're going to lose our oceans
because the sun is steadily
getting brighter over time.
So the surface temperature
increases, water boils,
turns into steam,
escapes into space.
We lose our oceans.
So people are saying,
well, that's the end.
And actually, today, it
seems like the end is about,
if you're a little
pessimistic, about 500
million years from now.
That's when the end begins.
And that's because, again,
the sun gets hotter.
And as the sun is
getting hotter,
the surface
temperature is rising.
And while that's happening,
the Earth's interior
is getting cooler and volcanism
is diminishing and declining.
We're going to reach
a point, essentially,
where this is going to throw
the carbon cycle out of whack.
And a lot of details
in the book--
I'm kind of glossing over this
part to get to some other juicy
stuff-- but
essentially, we may only
have about 500 million
years before this happens.
The carbon cycle goes
all out of whack.
Carbon dioxide in the atmosphere
is pulled out of the air
into the rocks.
There's no longer
any CO2 for plants
to use to drive photosynthesis.
So photosynthesis ends.
Plants die.
They're the base
of the food chain.
We die.
So that's kind of when that's
going to start happening.
Bacteria can exist a lot
longer, but we're not
talking about bacteria.
We're interested
in things like us.
in complex life.
So that's where the five
billion years comes in.
And the solitude part kind
of comes in from really
just what we're seeing
around us and what
we're seeing on our own planet.
The fact that, out of the 4
and 1/2 billion year history
of our planet, we
see no evidence
of anything else like us.
Nothing that could build
rockets, or radio telescopes,
nuclear bombs, or write
sonnets, or plays, or feel love.
There's not a lot
evidence of that.
I mean, even if you include
our hominid ancestors, that's
about 200,000 years,
maybe a million years
you're looking at,
it's not a lot.
So we're just a
blip, and we do seem
to be kind of special in the
fullness of the planet's life.
Similarly, you look out into
space, you see all these stars.
We now know there's lots of
planets around those stars.
We aren't looking very hard
yet, but we don't really
see anything else
like us out there.
We don't see any evidence of
any technological civilizations.
We don't see Captain
Kirk and the Enterprise
or Luke Skywalker
and the Death Star.
We don't see any of that.
It's deathly quiet.
So there's a lot of people
who talk about this much more
eloquently than I'm going
to, at least on stage.
Maybe the book's a
different matter.
But that kind of
speaks to me, and makes
me wonder whether or not we
are, in all practical purposes,
alone, and if we
really have what
it takes to kind of
break our solitude.
Because right now, we really
are on the cusp of doing things
like finding Earth-like planets
around the nearest thousand
stars, finding out whether
or not we're alone.
We're on the cusp of doing that.
We know how to do it.
We have the money.
We have the capability.
But it doesn't seem
like we have the will.
And I'm not really sure
if we're going to get it.
And so that's a little bit
of pessimism on my part,
and I hope I'm wrong.
But there you go.
So "Five Billion
Years of Solitude,"
that's kind of where
the title comes from.
So anyway, let's kind
of move on from that.
That's really an
overview of the book
and really broader
view of the book.
Talks about a lot
of different people
at the forefront of this
field in different areas.
But let's move on to
what I'm really here
to talk about, which is
about this revolution that's
unfolding right now for us.
The fact that right now, every
single person on this planet
is really occupying a profoundly
important and special moment
in history.
We're finally, finally
able, after four
and a half billion years of
this biosphere developing
on this planet, able to
go out and look around
all these stars, and the planets
are pouring out of the sky.
We've already found more
than 1,000 exoplanets.
I think, officially,
semi-officially,
depending on what you
define as a planet,
crossed that earlier this
month, that threshold of 1,000.
Those are confirmed exoplanets.
So there's way more
out there than we
have in our solar
system, obviously.
A single NASA
mission, Kepler, which
we'll talk a lot
more about in a bit,
has found more than 3,500
planetary candidates.
About 90% of those are
probably going to be legit.
So they're everywhere.
You can run the
statistics, and basically,
anytime you're looking up at
the sky and you see a star,
the chances are you're
looking at a planetary system.
That star probably has planets.
And this is kind of new,
and it's really exciting.
It's a really exciting
time to be alive.
So that's kind of
the big picture.
That's we're going to go.
Let's go a little deeper.
Let's talk about
we've found so far.
So how did this begin?
Where did this come from?
How long has this
been happening?
Well, you can see,
this is actually
a plot taken from the excellent
"Exoplanet Catalog" run
by a French astronomer
named Jean Schneider.
This is tracking
all the, I think
it's 1,039 planets
officially, exoplanets,
and it's tracking
mass on the y-axis
and the year of
discovery on the x-axis.
And you can just see here,
this little dot-- let
me get my laser
pointer, is it going
to work-- yeah, this little dot
right here, that was actually
discovered, as you
can see, in 1989.
It's kind of something
that's bigger than Jupiter.
Might be a brown dwarf.
We only went back and
realized what that was.
The first one that
really, really
got things started is right
here, and that's 51 Pegasi b.
That's a hot Jupiter that was
discovered around the star 51
Pegasi, a sun-like
star, in 1995.
And you can just kind
of see, you know?
Again, if you look at
planetary mass here,
so right here that's Jupiter.
That's Jupiter mass.
So here's 51 Pegasi.
And you can just see,
there's a couple here,
each year by year, little here.
Some droughts where you
don't even have any.
And then this happens.
And you can see that,
progressively, these individual
dots, each one of these
dots being a planet,
they're just blurring into lines
because we're finding so many
of these things.
And they're also getting
way lower in mass.
Right down here, that's
below Earth mass.
Earth mass is right around here.
So it's this huge
revolution, where we're just
getting better and
better at finding
smaller and smaller
things, and more
and more Earth-like orbits.
They're no longer just
these big balls of gas
hugging their stars like
the first planets were.
They're smaller planets,
potentially rocky planets.
Planets that could be quite
like Earth in nice orbits.
And this has been going on
for 20 years, obviously.
There's no sign
it's going to stop.
Keeps going.
But a lot of this
right down here,
when you really see just these
lines, these walls of worlds
right here, that's from Kepler.
Kepler's really special.
Let's talk about
Kepler a little more.
So this is a view,
Kepler's view.
This was launched in 2009.
It's a NASA spacecraft.
I think it was
about $600 million.
And it's looking at
this little, tiny swath
of stars that extends out to
about 3,000 light years away.
And we'll talk about
exactly how it's
looking for planets
in just a little bit,
but the important
thing to remember,
again, we're only looking
at a little tiny bit here.
It was on a three and
a half year mission.
Wildly successful, looking
at about 150,000 stars or so.
And again, it's looking mostly
for planets that are really
about the size of Earth
in year-long orbits
around sun-like stars.
The reason why it needed
at least three years
is because, well,
maybe we should
get into that a little later.
But it has to look for the
planet kind of going around
the star not once, not twice,
but three times, so for a year.
And yeah, it's just
been phenomenal.
It's found, as I mentioned, more
than 3,500 candidates already.
Of course, you may have
heard in May of this year,
it kind of suffered a
crippling malfunction.
It's not doing too well now.
A lot of its reaction
wheels aren't working,
so it can't really
point very well.
It's not totally dead yet,
but its glory days are over.
The Kepler wave, I think,
has kind of passed.
There's going to be a
lot of data analysis
to still do in the future,
but its glory days are gone.
So what has it told us so far?
This is brand new,
hot off the presses.
This is from last week, a
big Kepler meeting last week.
This is showing
you, essentially,
the breakdown of that 3,500-odd
candidates that they found.
You can see there's
a good number
of kind of super-Jupiters.
There's a hefty number
of Jupiter-sized planets.
And then you just
see this explosion
in Neptune-sized planets,
so-called super-Earth-sized
planets, and then
Earth-sized planets.
Now what's interesting about
this is that the super-Earths,
that green bar, as well as
the Neptune-sized planets,
that yellow bar,
that orange bar,
we really don't
have analogs at all
for these in our
own solar system.
These were not expected.
They were not predicted.
They're in relatively
short-period orbits,
most of them around
stars that are
smaller and dimmer than our sun.
Some of them potentially
could be habitable,
could potentially be
relative to the Earth-like,
rocky with thin atmospheres.
But it's hard to tell because
we don't know a lot about them.
And again, we have nothing
in our solar system
to study, really, that we
can use as a local analog.
There's nothing that's
two Earth radii.
There's nothing like
that in our solar system.
There's no Neptune that's parked
interior of Mercury's orbit
in our solar system.
But we're finding that
all over the place
when we look with Kepler.
And part of that
is selection bias,
but it is telling us that
our understanding of planet
formation is incomplete.
But you can look at this.
You can look at these
3,500 candidates or so,
and you can see, OK,
674 Earth-sized planets,
over a 1,000
super-Earth-sized planets?
Most of those are
candidates, but they're
going to be proved
legit eventually.
You might think that
maybe we've already
found kind of this
2.0-- Earth 2.0, right?
Maybe it's lurking
in there someplace?
Maybe.
I will go ahead and
make a prediction
and say that by the
end of the decade,
finding a potentially
habitable Earth-sized planet
around a sun-like star will
no longer be newsworthy
at all because it's
going to happen
so much that no one's
really going to care.
It's not going to be news.
So something to think about.
Let's see what we
really know about some
of these promising worlds.
This is a list, I think
it's relatively up
to date, of the current
potentially habitable
exoplanets according
to various metrics.
When we say
potentially habitable,
again, we're thinking
blinkered, thinking
about what Earth is like.
We think it needs to be rocky.
We think that it needs to have
a relatively thin atmosphere.
It's a big plus if
it has liquid water.
That's obviously the
basis for life here.
It needs to probably
be in what's
called be "habitable zone,"
right, this circumstellar,
Goldilocks, just-right
region, where
it's neither too hot nor
too cold for liquid water
to exist on a planet's surface.
So what you're looking at here,
this ranked list of 12 worlds,
is essentially, I
mean, all of these
have been claimed at one
time or another as Earth 2.0,
as they've all made
headlines as that.
And you can see, maybe
we have found Earth 2.0.
I mean, look at this.
Oh, you got some clouds.
You got some seas
there, some continents.
Lighting is a little
funny because it's around
really tiny stars.
But man, those look
pretty good, right?
Look like Earth.
Let's go pack up the starship.
Let's go.
Well, what do we really know?
What do we really know
about these places?
I got multiple clickers here.
I got to keep them straight.
All right.
So actually, pay attention
to this third one right
here, Gliese 581 g, number 3.
So what you're seeing right
here is the actual data.
This is what we're
going from the star.
This is all we know about that
planet, about this system.
That's it.
And I'll explain
it a little bit.
The way that we're getting
this planet's signature
is, essentially, it's
an indirect measurement,
and we're looking at the star
itself and the starlight.
And we can tell when
the star is kind
of wobbling back and forth
in our point of view,
red shift and blue shift.
The light will get
a little redder
when it's coming towards
us-- or I'm sorry,
going away from us
and a little bluer
when it's coming towards us.
So if you plot that over time,
you plot that motion over time,
you get this nice
little sine wave.
You get this nice little signal
of an orbiting planet that's
tugging on its star and
making the star wobble.
And as you can see,
you get its year.
You get its orbital
period by kind
of the repetition of this,
the peak and the trough.
The actual strength
of the signal,
how much it's
pulling on the star,
gives you an
estimate of its mass.
So you can get its mass.
You can get some orbital
characteristics about it.
And you can see here, if you
look at these little sidebars
right here, this is
in meters per second.
So you can see this signal is
on the order of-- it's like 10
meters per second.
Nice and clean, great.
That's not Gliese 581 g.
That's not the planet
that may be like Earth.
The planet that may be
like Earth that everyone
was trumpeting a couple
years back is this.
Look at that.
Doesn't look so hot, does it?
Not a lot of people are
convinced this planet exists.
I don't know whether
or not it exists.
You need to get more data.
And look at all those dots.
This is hundreds of measurements
using state of the art,
best things we got,
the best kit we have.
And that's the best
we can do right now.
Look at this measurement here.
I mean, it's on the order
of like a meter per second.
Now, you think about
a meter per second,
that's kind of like how
fast I'm walking right now.
And we're doing this for
an entire star that's
light years away, this big,
glowing plasmatic ball of gas.
It's remarkable that
we can do it at all.
But lots of things can kind of
occlude the signal, star spots,
big waves of plasma,
[INAUDIBLE] cycles.
So the point is is that
we have to be really
careful about the claims we
make about these planets,
these so-called
Earth-like planets,
because this is a case of
one-- again, front-page news.
I don't know if
you-- I mean, I keep
track of this better
than most people,
but it was front-page news.
It was all over the place,
and it might not even be real.
And even if it is
real, you're not
getting anything
about the atmosphere,
nothing about the surface,
nothing about the climate,
nothing that's going
to let you actually
anoint it as Earth-like.
So let's talk about
Kepler some more,
because this is obviously
not Kepler data.
We're all about Kepler.
Well, this is actually kind of
one of the Kepler prize finds,
the crown jewels.
This was announced earlier
this year in April.
What you're looking at is a
super-Earth called Kepler-62f.
It's about 40%
larger than Earth.
And you may notice that
little dot right there,
that bright-looking star thing.
That's not a star.
That's actually another
planet called Kepler-62e.
These things hug the opposite
cusps of the habitable zone
around this star,
which is slightly
smaller and dimmer than our sun.
So this is a case
where we're finding
two potentially habitable
planets in one system.
Great news, right?
I mean, Kepler-62f, the
main one you're seeing here,
ranks 10th in that-- it's
number 10 right there.
You can see it, little
orb, featureless orb.
Kepler-62e, you may
notice, its companion,
that's that little
star, is number 1.
So that's, supposedly,
prime real estate right now.
That's supposedly where we
should pack our starships
and go.
But again, what do we really
know about these planets?
So I'll show you again.
It's not a lot, not as
much as you'd think.
This is the data we
have for these planets.
Pump the brakes.
Don't get in your
starship quite yet.
This is Kepler-62e.
That's Kepler-62f.
What you're looking at here is
what's called a light curve.
This is how Kepler
finds planets.
It doesn't look for wobbles.
It doesn't look for
the wobbling star.
Instead, it looks
for these really rare
geometric alignments, where
the star crosses the face--
or I'm sorry, the planet,
sorry-- the planet
crosses the face of the
star as seen from Earth
or as seen from Kepler, and
it casts a little shadow
that we can detect.
And for things this small,
for things about Earth-sized,
that's pretty tough.
The Earth imparts a shadow
on the sun from interstellar
distances that is really minute.
I mean, there's no windows
in here, unfortunately,
but if you think
about a typical window
pane and the light
passing through,
the window pane
is actually going
to dim the light more than
an Earth across a sun.
So it's a really
faint measurement,
but we can measure it, and
it's remarkable that we can.
But you can just see
it's not a lot to go on.
We have this little kind
of a paucity of data here,
and we have these light curves.
And ideally, what you
want to do to kind
of weed out so-called false
positives-- because, again,
these light curves could
be caused by star spots
or eclipsing binary stars.
You have a pair of stars.
It could be caused by all kinds
of things that aren't planets.
You want to actually
get that wobble.
You want to get that
wobble measurement
to confirm each one of
these dips in starlight
is actually a planet.
But that takes a lot
of telescope time.
It's really tough to do.
And consequently, we
actually haven't done it
for these bottom
two worlds at least.
So we're pretty
confident they're
planets for various
other reasons,
but again, it's tough to do.
We don't really know.
There's always uncertainties.
But what's really cool, the
reason why I brought this up,
is because when you
get the wobble, when
you get that measurement
of the wobbling star,
and you pair it with
the light curve,
the light curve is
giving you the estimated
size of the planet.
The wobble is giving
you the estimated mass.
So let's put those together.
I know you're all
good at math, right?
Mass, size, you get density.
That's amazing.
So what we're doing is
we're finding these planets,
and we can actually
determine whether or not
they're mostly made of
something like water or rock
or metal or gas.
And that's phenomenal.
But it's not really enough.
It's really still not telling
us what we really want to know,
the Earth-like planets,
the planets that
might be like ours, the
planets that might harbor life
that we could maybe someday
go to like Von Braun wanted.
So you're probably thinking,
I didn't come here for this.
It's after lunch, I'm tired.
Like why is this guy
being such a buzzkill?
Why is this guy just going
on about all the things
we don't know?
I'm sorry.
I apologize.
But this is why.
This is why.
This, what you're
looking at right here,
is Venus as seen during its
transit last year, 2012.
I think this image is
really emblematic of where
we are right now in our search
for habitable exoplanets.
You can kind of
look at it, and you
can tell that that's a planet.
You can get an
estimate of its size.
Maybe you can figure out
its mass a little bit.
You can get its orbital period.
But there's not a
lot to go on there.
You really don't
know much about it.
And what's important about
this, and what's particularly
kind of resonant, is that
you have to remember that,
up until the 1950s, for
centuries people thought
that Venus was a
wonderful place to live
because it gets more sunlight.
But it's covered with
clouds, and those clouds
act like a shield.
So they, essentially,
reflect more sunlight,
so it's really
doing pretty well.
If you just run the simple math,
it should be nice down there
and clement.
And people for a
long time thought
there was going to be like
carboniferous jungles,
and dinosaurs, and
flying men, things
like that, all kinds
of crazy stuff.
And wasn't until the
1950s that we actually
started getting a better idea.
We started looking at
microwave radiation coming out
of the atmosphere.
It was suggested it was
hot enough to melt lead.
We started seeing things like
polarization measurements
of its atmosphere that suggested
that it had sulfuric acid rain.
And now, of course,
we send probes.
We know that it's a
terrible place to live.
It's the worst place to live in
the solar system pretty much.
But we were fooled for a long
time for pretty sound reasons.
And the whole point is that
this is a world right next door
that we thought was
Earth-like for a long time.
We were totally wrong.
And we need to keep this in mind
when we make claims or believe
what's in the headlines about
all these other planets that
are being found.
So I really want
to drive that home.
But this image is also
emblematic for another reason,
and it's positive, not negative.
This is where we start talking
about the really cool stuff
that can happen.
So look at this right here.
I don't know if you
can see it, but there's
this little tiny
line that's just
limning the planet, this
little arc of starlight.
What that is is it's
actually the sunlight
blasting through the
upper atmosphere of Venus.
We can actually, if
we study it properly,
we can determine-- it tells us
a lot about Venus's atmosphere.
And we can do this for
exoplanets, which is wild.
So this is kind of
how the process works.
I'll simplify it a bunch.
What you need to remember is
that whenever light interacts
with matter, matter kind
of imprints its fingerprint
on the light.
I shouldn't say matter, but
not dark matter and stuff,
but normal stuff
like us, things that
are made out of
elements, chemicals.
So it imprints its
fingerprints on the light.
You can split it
up into a spectrum.
You can see little peaks and
valleys, little absorption
lines and emission lines.
You can figure out
what stuff is made of.
That's how we know what
the stars are made of.
That's how we know the galaxy
is made of the same things
that we are.
So obviously,
pretty basic stuff.
But yeah, you can actually get
this for transiting planets.
You can detect that signal.
And we've already done it for
some big, hot, puffy worlds,
again, some of these hot
Jupiters that transit.
We've already gotten
these signals.
We've seen things like sodium in
their atmospheres or potassium.
If you did this
for Venus, and you
had a big enough spectrometer
or big enough mirror
to gather all the
light, you'd see
that there's so much CO2
in that upper atmosphere,
and there's no
water vapor at all.
That would suggest probably
not a good place to live.
Don't pack your rockets.
So this is a nice way forward.
This is a way we can actually
study exoplanets going
into the future and get a good
sense of maybe what they're
like, get more information to
pin down our potential targets,
our other Earths.
And what's really exciting
is NASA, to its credit,
has actually started work on
a follow-up mission to Kepler
called TESS, the Transiting
Exoplanet Survey Satellite,
suppose to launch in 2017.
It's actually not going to be
able to do this measurement,
but it's going to be able to get
targets for this measurement.
Because Kepler stars
are mostly too far away.
They're thousands
of light years away.
We can't get enough
photons from them
to get this kind of
measurement from them.
But if there's
transiting planets,
transiting Earth-sized
planets that
are around nearby stars in
our cosmic neighborhood,
well, we could investigate
those with the right kind
of telescope.
So what kind of telescope
are we talking about?
We're talking about this
thing, this behemoth.
It's great.
It's a workhorse.
It is starving NASA
of all its money,
or NASA astrophysics anyway.
It's the James Webb
Space Telescope.
This is a full-size model out
of Goddard Space Flight Center.
You can see how honking
huge this thing is.
It's got a 6.5-meter
mirror, primary mirror.
That's all those
golden hexagons.
That gray stuff
you're looking at
is a sun shield that's about
the size of tennis court.
This is all going to
be cryogenically cooled
when it gets into space.
It's going to be packed
and folded into a rocket
and shot beyond
the Moon, and then
unfold like kind of like a
piece of origami out there.
And it really needs to
work because if it doesn't,
bad, bad, bad things
happen, and we've
lost at least a generation of
astronomy and space science.
So it's kind of all-in bet.
But here's kind
of the tough part
to admit about it is
that James Webb is going
to be able to do this
so-called transit spectroscopy,
getting that information
for potentially habitable
super-Earth planets around
a handful of nearby stars.
It's mostly going to be
looking for water vapor.
And there's a lot of debate
over just what James Webb can
do, just what Webb can do.
And I have to say I'm kind
of a pessimist on this.
It's supposed to launch in 2018,
so we'll find out pretty soon,
I hope.
But yeah, it was designed
to study the first stars
and galaxies, not exoplanets.
And if you look at what's
needed to do this measurement,
to get that little beam
of starlight coming
around the planet's
edge, its silhouette,
it's really going to
work best for kind
of puffy planets, things that
have big, extended atmospheres,
things that might have
runaway greenhouses
and might be much more
like Venus than like Earth.
So I'm not really
very optimistic
about us getting the answers
we want, or the answers I want,
which is, again, finding Earth
twins, finding life out there.
I don't think Webb's
going to do it.
I hope I'm wrong.
But the other thing
you have to think about
is that, again, we're
talking about transits.
So this is the other aspect
of why it's not that great.
Remember how I
mentioned that transits
are a product of really
rare geometric alignment?
How often do you look out there?
How often do you think a planet
is going to be aligned just so,
so that it crosses
the face of its star
and casts a shadow
towards Earth?
It's pretty rare.
Doesn't happen
very often at all.
So most of the planets
that are out there
are going to be totally
invisible to us.
We can't investigate
them this way.
And that's a problem because
you need a big sample size.
We still don't really
understand how life formed here.
There's a lot of questions
we don't understand.
We don't quite know exactly
what we're looking for.
You need to have as big
a sample as possible.
So if James Webb can do this
for like 10 or 12 potentially
habitable planets, that's great.
But what if you
find nothing at all?
You don't know what
that's telling you
because your sample
size is too small.
But let's say it
goes for 50 or a 100
or a 1,000 exoplanets,
potentially habitable
exoplanets, which it can't do.
But if we could get that
kind of sample size,
well, all of a sudden,
you can run statistics.
You can kind of know
what's going on.
You can get a signal
out of that measurement.
So what's that going to take?
How are we going to get this
sample of 1,000 nearby stars
or something like that?
Well, this is how
we need to do it.
This is an example of what's
called direct imaging.
This is a picture from the
Hubble Space Telescope.
It's a planet, or what's
thought to be a planet,
about Jupiter mass,
orbiting the star Fomalhaut.
Now, you probably
look at it, and it
doesn't look that impressive.
But again, Jupiter-mass planet.
Also, it looks like it's
relatively close, but it's not.
This thing is about four
times further out than Pluto.
This thing is cold
and far, far out.
Actually, it's kind
of a little hot, which
is why it's able to
be detected this way.
And so this is kind of
cutting-edge stuff right now,
but we're going to need
to do a lot better.
We're going to need to get
a lot closer into the star,
into the so-called habitable
zone, image things that
are a lot smaller.
And to do that, the best
way to really compare it
is like saying there's a firefly
orbiting the world's largest
and most powerful spotlight,
maybe like less than a meter
away, probably 10
centimeters away.
And that's happening in LA,
and we're here in New York
trying to look at it.
And you have to blot out all
that light from the spotlight
just to see that faint firefly.
Another way to look
at it is it's like,
and this is really
much more true,
it's like an unlit match
kind of on the cusp
of a detonating hydrogen
bomb, a thermonuclear
reactor like stars are, right?
So it's like that kind
of contrast ratio.
It's on the order of 10
billion stellar photons
for every single one planetary
photon we want to get.
Now, that sounds really tough.
There's a lot of ways we've
kind of figured out in the lab
to get that
starlight suppressed.
But what it really does
require, if you just kind of say
we can do the
starlight suppression,
is it requires a
big mirror in space,
which means it's
going to be expensive.
Well, how big are
we talking about?
We're talking about
something this big.
So you've got Hubble
Space Telescope,
revolutionizes astronomy,
two and a half meters or so.
James Webb, going to
revolutionize astronomy too,
six and a half meters.
These are two
notional designs for
planet-finding,
life-finding telescopes.
You can tell by the
acronym, ATLAST,
that astronomers
have been looking
for this for a long time.
Eight meters, 16 meters.
This eight-meter,
if we ever build it,
would be able to
get us the spectra,
the atmospheric information
and things for hundreds
of nearby planets,
rather planets
around hundreds of nearby stars.
And that 16-meter,
that behemoth,
we're talking about
thousands of nearby stars
we can investigate for
potentially Earth-like planets.
So this is really exciting.
Why don't we just go out
and build that, right?
Oh, I should also say that
these ATLAST designs are
just two of kind of a whole
suite of telescopes that exist
or notionally exist that have
been designed to do this.
They come in all
different flavors.
And kind of
collectively, NASA has
tended to call them TPFs, or
Terrestrial Planet Finders.
And around the turn of the
century, in the 2000s actually,
they were spending to the
tune of $50 million per year
to try to make
these things happen.
Originally, they were going
to launch a pair of them.
The first one was going to
operate in visible light.
It was going to launch
next year, in 2014.
Then there was going to be a
more sophisticated, little more
expensive, infrared version that
was going to launch in 2020.
Well, I guess you
may have guessed,
but we haven't been hearing
about these telescopes
really very much
recently, and that's
because they were officially
deferred indefinitely in 2006.
There just wasn't enough money.
And that's because, again, these
things are really expensive.
We're talking on the
order of $10 billion,
and that's a lot
of money for NASA.
That's not just chump
change you can dig out
of the couch cushions
unfortunately.
Maybe there's another
way to do this.
Maybe NASA isn't the only way.
I think it's relevant
that I'm speaking
at one of the biggest, most
powerful companies in the world
right now who tends to fund
all kinds of crazy things.
Something to think about.
But meanwhile,
the whole point is
that as we're dithering and
debating over whether or not
we can do this-- and
just for perspective,
the amount of money
we're talking about,
again, is like a couple of
weeks worth of war in the Middle
East, maybe how much we
spend on Halloween candy
each year, or pets, right?
So it's not, in the big scheme
of things, that much money,
and it's a pretty
big payoff, I think.
But while we're
debating and dithering
of whether we can do this,
the planets are just,
they're going to keep piling up.
By 2020, it's not
going to be a big deal
to find these potentially
habitable planets.
But the difference is
is that we aren't going
to know what they're
actually like,
and there's this
huge, yawning gap.
Right now, officially, NASA
is thinking about maybe,
maybe doing this in the 2030s.
That just seems like a
long time to wait for me.
Maybe I'm just impatient.
So this is my final slide.
This is kind of
the payoff, right?
So OK, we make these
big investments.
We build a telescope or
two that can do this.
What's it going to look like?
What's it going to do for us?
Well, you may
recognize this image.
I have doctored it a
little bit, obviously,
with this blue circle.
Earth does not have rings.
That is Earth taken by Voyager
1 from a viewpoint of about four
billion miles away,
passing over to Pluto.
This was taken in, I
think, 1990, not 1991,
and this kind of approximates
what we would see.
If we build one of
these telescopes,
and we find a little promising
planet and we image it,
this might be what it looks
like, a "pale blue dot,"
as Carl Sagan called it.
Well, it doesn't
seem very impressive
until you realize how
much we can take out
of that "pale blue dot,"
the way we can data mine it.
So just look at its
brightness change, the way
that, as it rotates,
depending on the geometry,
if we're lucky, as
it rotates, and we
see the kind of fluctuation of
illumination on its surface,
if you kind of track that over
a long enough period of time
via photometry,
light curves, you
can pin down its rotation rate.
You can get the
length of its day.
If you get that,
you can bin it up,
you can bin up the data
day by day by day by day.
You know what's passing
under you each time.
And you can start to see things
like oceans, or grasslands,
or deserts because these all
have different reflectance.
Grasslands are kind
of medium, mid-scale.
You have oceans that
are really dark.
They absorb a lot of light,
except when they kind of have
to glint every now
and then, which
is its own thing that
we can use to map.
And then you have deserts or ice
that are extremely reflective.
So you can do very, very
crude mapping, Google mapping
of other planets beyond
the solar system.
You can do that with
just that point of light.
Again, it's crude,
but you can always
build a bigger space
telescope, right?
The other thing you can do,
of course, is get spectra.
You can get atmospheric spectra.
You can figure out what's
in that atmosphere.
And when we do this
for Earth-- there's
another famous spacecraft
from NASA called Galileo that
did this for Earth,
I believe, in 1991.
You can see the breath of life,
literally, in our atmosphere.
You can see free oxygen.
Oxygen is a very reactive gas.
It doesn't want to really
hang around in the air.
It wants to fall out
of the air and rust.
It wants to go into rocks.
Yet somehow, our
atmosphere is 21% oxygen.
You can see methane.
Methane also does
not really want
to hang around in the
atmosphere, especially
when there's oxygen around.
You put oxygen and
methane into a sealed box
at room temperature
and pressure,
it's going to turn into carbon
dioxide and water vapor.
Yet somehow, we still
have this breath
of methane, this wisp of
methane in our atmosphere.
So you can look at
that, put it together,
and you can kind of
think, well, you know,
it's kind of out of
chemical equilibrium,
out of thermodynamic
equilibrium profoundly
by many, many, many
orders of magnitude.
And we can't really think of
a better explanation for that.
Again, we're blinkered.
We're looking here on Earth.
We don't know the whole panoply
of life that exists out there.
But that's a pretty
good signature of life
as far as we can
understand it, and we've
done it for our own planet
from the depths of space.
So that's kind of
the big picture.
That's what we're trying to do.
That's what I think
people should get excited
about for the coming
generations of astronomy.
And I guess I'll just close
by saying this is something
that I believe in
fervently, obviously.
A lot of other people in the
book believe in it a lot.
And I do think that this
is the kind of thing
that we could really
do quite soon.
I think this is
the kind of thing
that, if we really wanted
to, we could do in a decade.
But the way things
are going right now,
it looks like we're all going
to be old and grey or dead
by the time it happens.
So I hope that we
can change that.
So with that, I'll go ahead
and take your questions.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hey.
So you talked a lot about
upcoming space telescopes.
What about upcoming
ground telescopes?
I know there are quite a
few of those being planned.
What can they
contribute to this?
LEE BILLINGS: Great question.
They can do a lot.
It depends on kind of
what you're going for.
They can do a whole lot in
terms of trying to pin down,
for instance, a lot of
the Kepler candidates.
They can maybe measure
some of those wobbles,
so you can actually get the
mass as well as the size
and get the density.
Confirm it's actually a
planet instead of a candidate.
More importantly,
we're really coming
to this dawning era of
extremely, extremely
large telescopes.
These are huge
things that are going
to have big
light-collecting surfaces,
I think on the order of 30
meters, and that's really big.
And these things, these
kind of big light buckets,
are probably going
to be coming online
by the end of the decade.
There's various different
projects, the giant Magellan
Telescope, the
30-meter telescope.
There's a few others.
And hopefully,
they're going to come
online by the end of the decade.
Those could, in theory,
do some measurements,
get some spectra
for, really, kind
of super-Earth-sized planets
that are orbiting red dwarf
stars, which are much smaller
and dimmer than our sun,
and particularly when
they're transiting.
But if you look at the contrast
ratio of that really small, dim
star, that really big
planet transiting across it,
that's actually a signal that,
especially in the infrared
like what you can get from the
top of a mountain someplace,
you could conceivably get some
legit, nice atmospheric spectra
from.
But it's only going to be
able to do that, they're only
going to be able to do
that, as far as I know,
for a handful of
stars in the sky.
So this really gets
back to the question of,
what's your sample size?
If you want to investigate
hundreds of stars or thousands
of stars, what you
probably need to do
to find some other
planet that's like ours,
then you have to go to space.
Otherwise, you're really
depending on luck.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
for coming first.
So let's say that we are lucky,
and by 2050, hopefully we'll
all be alive by then, we'll
find a very good candidate,
like 95% certainty, 20
light years from Earth.
What will we be able
to do about that?
LEE BILLINGS: Well,
I mean, in some ways,
we're only limited by the laws
of physics and our imagination.
I think that what we do
about it is-- I mean,
it's kind of up to, I guess,
whoever's in charge then.
But I mean, you can think about
all kinds of grandiose notions
of building some kind
of small robotic probe,
maybe a series of
them, maybe about
the size of Coke can,
maybe send voyaging at 10%
the speed of light.
I think that's
probably something
we could figure out how to do.
Maybe it could return
some close-up images.
You could think about
things like that.
You can think about building an
even bigger telescope or even
fleets of telescopes.
Right now I've been
restricting this conversation,
just to simplify it, to filled
apertures, big pieces of glass,
big mirrors in space.
One of the most
exciting things is
to go with unfilled apertures,
to use interferometry
to actually link together kind
of like a hyper-telescope.
You link together a lot of
small, individual apertures,
maybe dishes that are
about a meter in size,
but you get a lot
of them, and you
get a big, big
baseline stretched out.
And then you get
enough of that, you
can get some pretty crazy
surface feature map.
And you can do things like,
I mean, in simulations
and looking at Earth
from 10 parsecs, say,
you can see things like
phytoplankton blooms
in the Pacific Ocean.
You can see coastlines.
You can see mountains.
You can see nighttime
electric lighting.
You can see New York City.
You can see LA.
So there's things
that we can think
of that we could do that
are even more futuristic,
or we could try to go there.
But for me, it's not
so much about what
do we do then, necessarily,
it's just the fact
that we're kind of
on the cusp of being
able to do these things,
of being able to find out
whether or not we're alone for
the first time in the history
of the biosphere, in four
and a half billion years.
And I'm actually somewhat
more compelled by the notion
that we'll look
out there, and we
aren't going to find
anything like that.
And I think if
that happens, then
I don't know if it will really
change the lives of people,
everyday people on the street.
But I think for people
who think about it,
it might kind of change
how you look at the world
and how you look
at your own life
if you realize that
for, let's say,
a radius of 500
light years or 300
light years around
the Earth, this
is literally the
coolest thing going.
I think that's a powerful
thing to think about.
And I think if we
had that realization,
maybe we'd take a
little better care
of ourselves and our planet.
AUDIENCE: Sort of
along the same lines,
I mean, if we're
looking for company,
it would seem that
something like SETI
would be more interesting than
looking for other planets that
happen to have oxygen.
It might be that all the
cool people out there
are nitrogen-based
except for us.
Who knows?
LEE BILLINGS: Right.
Yeah, no.
That's a great question.
And this is not, in any
way, meant to bash SETI.
I think SETI is great.
I think it's
tragically underfunded.
It's been tragically underfunded
the entirety of its existence.
And Frank Drake first pointed
a telescope at Epsilon Eridani
in Taos SETI.
But the problem with
that is that I think
we have this really
kind of-- you
know, the inverse-square
law is a real thing.
And if you look at
our own emanations,
people sometimes think that,
oh, if they're out there,
they already know we're here
because of "I Love Lucy"
or whatever that's
going out there.
But I don't think so.
I think if you look at
how big, at least as far
as we understand it,
how big the hardware
has to be to detect that even
just a few light years away,
I don't think so.
So the point is is that all
this radio communication,
or communication
via laser pulses,
whatever it is, it
requires intentionality.
It requires someone
saying, huh, I
don't want to invest billions
of dollars, a lot of treasure,
a lot of time, into beaming
this message out into space.
And we're listening
for those messages,
and I'm not saying
that's bad to do.
I think we should do it.
But oxygen in an atmosphere,
this kind of disequilibrium
we're talking about-- and it
doesn't just have to be oxygen,
there's other
things we could look
for-- there's no
intentionality required.
It's just something that's
a product of metabolism.
Life exists.
And as far we know it,
life has to maintain
its orderly structures,
so it vents byproducts.
So if you can detect
that in an atmosphere,
it doesn't really
matter whether or not
the little green men want to
talk to you, you can find them.
So that's why I think this is a
little, maybe, more important.
Shouldn't say more important,
but maybe prioritize that.
Then we find the cool stuff.
Then we do the SETI
with the big dishes.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I saw that India recently
launched a Mars mission,
I guess.
Are other countries or
other space programs
doing anything interesting?
LEE BILLINGS: Well,
a guy once told me
that the best way to
make this stuff happen
is actually to convince the
Chinese to go out and find
the nearest 100
potentially habitable
planets and name them all after
departed emperors and things.
Right now,
unfortunately, there's
not a lot of activity
internationally.
ESA, the European Space
Agency, is doing some things.
They have some really
exciting missions proposed.
There's one called
"KEOPS," CHEOPS, "KEOPS."
There's another
one called PLATO.
But these are not kind of
"Battlestar Galactica" scale,
really large missions
that are going
to be able to bring home
the bacon, so to speak.
The European Space
Agency was on board
with NASA for these
terrestrial planet finders
earlier last decade.
But again, NASA decided we
should go back to the Moon
instead and keep doing a
few more shuttle flights
and did that.
So right now, it
is mostly the US,
but the US isn't
really doing much.
No one's really doing a lot.
AUDIENCE: It's me again.
So I have a theory.
It's extremely expensive
to launch things to space,
especially if we want to
put them in the Lagrange 1
point, which no one
ever done so far.
So we don't even know
if we can do that.
Maybe it's going to be
more efficient to be
a little bit more
strategic about it
and invest in ways to deliver
things to space in a cheaper
fashion, so that
this will be easier
to bring those big telescopes.
LEE BILLINGS: No,
you're totally right.
I mean, the main
cost, the reason
why these things
cost so much and they
take so long to develop is
because they can't fail.
James Webb is a great example.
Again, it's kind of got the
astrophysics program of NASA
on the ropes because
it's so expensive.
It's over budget.
These things are so
expensive because they
have to be launched into space.
They have to be built
to not fail in space.
to survive the launch.
And it's just expensive to get
out into space fundamentally,
especially if you're doing
something like the shuttle.
I mean, that was
ridiculously expensive.
If we can bring
launch costs down
via like an Elon Musk
Space X, things like that,
or if we can find a way
to maybe build things
modularly, right,
just like we do
on ground-based observatories.
No one assembles
a whole telescope
in a basement someplace, and
then hikes it up a mountain,
and puts it up there,
and expects it to work.
Instead, you build
it on the mountain,
and you bring it into
alignment, and you
make it work from there.
We could do that in space too.
And there's a guy in the book,
the director of the Space
Telescope Science
Institute, Matt Mountain,
who's a very big
proponent of this idea.
He thinks that it's a good
mission for NASA and for NASA's
Astronaut Corps to do in
the interim of going to Mars
or whatever.
I think it's more exciting
than visiting an asteroid,
personally, if we could build
a big planet-finding space
telescope up there and
service it in space.
That's awesome.
I think we should do that.
So these are ideas that
everyone's thinking about.
And I think you're
on the right track
that we need to get
launch costs down.
We also need to,
frankly, I think, get
space science solely out of the
hands of big federal agencies
probably.
Anymore?
AUDIENCE: I think it was
Neil deGrasse Tyson who
said that if you just
convince the Chinese to launch
a massive space program, the
US will be on Mars in a decade.
But you mentioned
earlier that it's
kind of tough to
get people excited
about this kind of exploration
because it's so commonplace,
I think.
Someone mentioned SETI earlier.
One cool thing they did, maybe
like six or seven years ago,
was they had this
program run out
of their institute
in Berkeley, I think,
where they leveraged
the power of the web
to get a lot of this
heavy processing.
And just where they were
lacking the computer power,
they just set up this proxy
service where people at home
could volunteer their
computers to help process
this massive corpus of data
that they were taking in
from all their satellites.
LEE BILLINGS: I'm a
SETI@home volunteer.
So yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do you think
we'll ever get to the point
where if web is giving us
so much more information
than we can possibly
sift through
in any reasonable time,
that we could leverage
the power of the web to help
quicken the search, I guess?
LEE BILLINGS: That's
a great question,
and the great part of the answer
is that we're already doing it.
There's a great program called
Planet Hunters that's-- I mean,
I think a lot of funding for
it comes through The Planetary
Society, which I recommend
everyone support.
And this is something that
actually looks at light curves
from Kepler.
I mean, we talk about planets
pouring out of the sky.
I mean, Kepler's
like a fire hose
that we're all
trying to drink from.
There's so much data
that's coming out of it.
The telescope's kind of out
of commission right now.
It had this pointing
error, so it's not even
delivering a lot of new data.
We're still processing
through, churning
through all that
data from last year.
So we haven't even
processed it all.
And Planet Hunters
is this great project
where-- yeah, you go through
and everything's automated is
what I'm saying for Kepler.
So much of it is
just algorithmic,
where it's like
you flag something.
OK, maybe this is of
interest, goes in this bin.
Oh, it's not, goes in this bin.
Well, algorithms are imperfect,
and they don't always
catch things that human eyes do.
And so Planet Hunters,
volunteers go through,
and they look through
the light curves,
tag things that look promising.
And actually, they
recently discovered
a seven-planet system.
That's, I think, maybe the
second seven-planet system,
maybe even the first
that Kepler has found.
And that was through
volunteer effort,
and I think there's a
huge potential for that.
But I just want to say,
the other half of that
is that I think we can't
get too kind of lost
in the woods of thinking about
like Kickstarter-like stuff.
Because volunteer work is
great, and that kind of activity
is great, where you're sifting
through data and stuff.
I'm a little more not so wild
about the notion that we're all
going to Kickstarter fund
like a big space telescope
to find other Earths.
Just because like,
I mean, how often
does a $5 billion
Kickstarter program happen?
And the other
question is like, you
know, it's kind of an
abdication of what we-- I mean,
the biggest Kickstarter thing,
the biggest crowdfunded thing
we have is what we
pay in taxes, right?
I mean, NASA, in a
way, is crowdfunded.
It's funded by us.
So I think that if you're
just either resorting
to the beneficence
of billionaires
to do this or the
crowd, well, you're
really missing the fact that,
well, what is NASA doing?
And then you have to question,
what is NASA's purpose?
So I think that before we get
on the bandwagon of that kind
of thing, we have
to really consider
what we already
have on the table.
AUDIENCE: Well, thanks.
LEE BILLINGS: Well, it's
been a lot of fun, guys.
Is there anymore questions?
We can always talk afterwards.
I know that everyone's
probably got
other things they got to do.
So thanks.
[APPLAUSE]